[Music]
on today's show we have a special show
where we talk about trauma and how to
heal from trauma
we take one call from a gentleman who is
in the audience of a presentation i gave
recently
who wanted some specific information on
how to take the bricks out of his
backpack
special show stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john deloney show
i hope you're doing well and you are
taking care of those that you love and
those that
love you or helping take care of you
[Music]
on this show we talk about mental health
relationships
laughter and joy and sadness and
everything in between and look
we've got a loaded audience out there
today of
four one four it's incredible to see you
guys
man five we got a fifth one over there
that's watching over james and kelly's
shoulder to make sure they're doing
their jobs
sir they are they're the two best in the
in the business in the biz as they say
they're awesome
hey thank you all for being here and um
we are glad that everyone's here kelly
james y'all doing well
yes sir doing great yep doing well
sir huh is that where we're at i was
feeling polite today
i appreciate that made me feel like i'm
back at a real job that was
that was awesome i'm not going to do
that sorry you're not and i wouldn't
ever expect it i think something's wrong
if you said that that would be weird hey
okay so today we've got a
different a different kind of show
um actually first before we tell you
about the um what kind of show we're
going to do today if you want to be on
this show we take calls
about real things going on real people's
lives and we walk alongside
you and so give me a call at 1-844-6900
and leave a message and kelly will
listen to those messages and get back in
touch with you and set you up to be on
the show
or you can go to ask john
ramseysolutions.com go to johndaloni.com
show and you can fill out the form
and we would really love to talk with
you
and we get calls from all over the world
about all different sorts of things
things that i thought i'd seen it all
and i have not so it is fantastic
and we are learning as we go so um
1-844-693-3291
so today is a special show um a few
weeks ago
i went with a crew to dallas to speak at
a large event um there's a couple two or
three thousand folks there
and man it was cool it was patrick
lincione
and jocko and a former president there
was a number of folks there it was
just a really remarkable event and i
gave a talk
about dealing with trauma and
the analogy i used for trauma you've
heard me use it on the show a lot is
this idea that we carry around bricks in
our backpack and
after the after the talk um i was really
floored with the response it was
something that um i wasn't expecting
i feel pretty good about public speaking
but it was it was nothing like what i
was expecting
and overwhelmingly positive and folks
begin
writing in and calling in and asking
okay so
what do i do with these bricks how do i
deal with that so
what we want to do today was we've got a
call that we'll get to here in a little
bit but i wanted to back out and just
walk folks through
my thought process and how i've lived
some of this out of my own life
and really man i've just worked with
hundreds of people
thousand bright on their trauma
on the bricks in the backpack how do
they get to a place where they can make
the next right decision
right so here's here's me backing
all the way out in high school
i think i was a freshman um there was
this big camp summer
camp that i went to every year and at
this summer camp
there was a talent show and there's
probably a thousand kids at this camp
and then you had adults in campus so put
yourself in this auditorium it's
completely packed it's not like a school
cafeteria touring but it's a big giant
auditorium
and um lights the sound system the whole
thing and i'm sitting up on a chair
and i sang a song that i wrote
and it was just a silly song about i
don't know
dating and girls and whatever so i sing
this song it's a big
hit and everything goes great and a big
the big selling point was i wrote this
song
right i didn't
what actually happened was a couple
weeks before camp there was this
live recording that i had heard it was
like a bootleg of
a pearl jam concert and i was listening
to it with a couple of
my buddies who were in my high school
rock band we were incredible by the way
and we were not but we were awesome and
so
we were listening to this it was awesome
we talked back and forth and
they played this new song and i just
remembered how
catchy the hook of this song was the
chorus was and
at that point i've been playing guitar
for a long time and you can you can pick
a chord progression out of the air
and you just learn the melodies real
quick and
so i took this really catchy chorus
and i attached it to some cheesy words
and i told everybody i wrote this song
it was all well and good until those
idiots in pearl jam decided to
quote unquote release the song in the
fall
suddenly i got letters as a 14 year old
from all over the country
about wow you're a writer for pearl jam
how cool how did you get that gig how
did they find out about your song that
you sing
at church camp how how did that happen
that's so great and then one guy just
wrote
a letter and he just said dude i think
you're a liar
and he was pretty much hit the nail on
the head there right so i was 14
and straight up busted so next year i go
back to this church camp and it's kind
of the buzz
like wow dude what a what a loser
um and then you got to come up with i
came up with all these excuses and tried
to wiggle my way out of it right but
it was a mess and if i back up before
that
um in fourth grade i was playing tag
with
a girl i had a crush on um
am i like can i say their name we had
there's a lot of people listen to this
now we have far exceeded our our 19
listeners
um so there's this girl ahead and fourth
grader name was rhonda i won't say her
last name but man i was in love
with her and we were playing tag or
something after school
in the cafeteria and i was so what you
do when you like somebody in your fourth
grade right is you
play tag and you push and shove and be
silly and
anyway man we were i was sprinting after
her
and she made a turn or started to make a
turn right by the wall and i went to
to tag her and i pushed her a little bit
and i tell you what uh i remember
i've seen a lot of trauma just worked
with a lot of traumatic
um crisis situations i remember her
scream
as she was smashed up against that wall
she broke both wrists
in that and um i
that's her scream is lodged into my soul
i remember it
i'll never forget it and for weeks i
guess months afterwards she
had both arms were in a cast and it
turned into this
we're just playing having fun and it got
real serious real fast right
um another one in in high school my
senior year my
i dropped the baton in i was the anchor
of the mile relay
in the district track meet and we lost
by one point
and um that was the first loss in 10
years
i was about to do the decade sweep and i
dropped it and that's that's still
to this day right so even thinking up to
like a few weeks ago a few months ago my
son
it was just hey dad hey dad hey dad hey
dad and i was doing something trying to
fix the mower some dead thing and hey
dad hey daddy dad and i finally just
turned and said
what well you just stopped for a second
right so i was loud
and then he his eyes get big because i
don't usually raise my voice and i don't
usually snap like that and
he backed up and said hey sorry sorry
dad sorry dad and then of course i was
like man i want an
idiot to myself right so i
i tell you those those stories right
because my life's been this circus of
bad decisions and crazy situations and
wild stories
and that doesn't include i mean that's
the ones we can tell on the
podcast right the ones that the statute
of limitations is running out on
um but there was times you know i lied
about stuff and stole things and didn't
have discipline i cut corners and blamed
other people
man i used to lie and steal all the time
as a kid it's one of those things that
haunts me as an adult
and then there's times that i came
through in the clutch and turned my life
around
and then times i didn't come through the
clutch right so it's when times when you
get the big job and then times when
you don't get the big job and it goes to
somebody else and you quit a job and you
wish you could have that job back and
we all have these stories right it's
childhood mayhem and accidents
and then it goes to things your dad said
that still rattle around in your head
right or the way
like after the first time you kiss
somebody and you back up and you look at
him in the eyes
and you know that was a terrible kiss or
or you look in the eye and think that
like that was incredible
right or the first time your mom slammed
the cabinets in in
anger or first time you were abused by
someone who loved you or the first time
you backed your car into something the
first time your
checking account goes into the red right
it's all of these moments
i remember the time i turned in a
multi-million dollar
performer for a residence hall to a
college president
and they had he told me to put together
a you know
amortization schedule for the debt
service against this large residence
hall and so i put together
on a word document and i highlighted
words and i changed the fonts there's
probably some comic sans in there
and i'll never forget handing it to him
in a big fancy meeting
in his face it looked like i just handed
him a plate of diarrhea that's what his
face
looked like just it was
like it wasn't even shame it was like
what what what am i
looking at did you hear me at like a
multi-million dollar performer on a on a
did you write a story is this a poem and
i just remember feeling so ashamed that
i went and hired
a senior in college to come teach me
excel
in like alone i told them this is like a
big secret right so
you have these moments right and man
it all comes back to these stories right
these stories these stories and they
become a part of us
and so when i meet with folks even as
late as this past weekend
there's a couple came out to work on
their marriage to stand at our house and
it never ceases to amaze me how these
stories especially these ones from
childhood
follow us around they follow us around
forever
right because here's what happened those
stories i told you when you're 14 of
course you tell big stories and i just
happened to be on a stage and
it became a real big one right or
playing as
a as a nine-year-old right these things
happen that's just
life but what we don't often realize
is how long and i'm talking about i'm
many many many decades later
um that i still carry around this tag
that i'm a liar
right or i still carry around this
notion that if you screw around
a kid is going to get hurt really really
bad and it's going to be your fault
right i still still lodged in there or
when the game is on the line
if deloney's fourth leg he's probably
gonna screw something up
right and that is translated into my
marriage into business into parenting
right
and of course you know you snap at your
kid
the logical conclusion is because you
suck at being a dad right you're just a
crappy dad
and these stories hang around and i feel
them in my body
in the present time even though they
haven't happened for years
right i am comically uh obnoxiously
um i used to steal out as a kid i'll
drive an hour out of the way to take a
quarterback
like a like if somebody overpays me i'm
so obnoxious about it now
uh i'm pathological about truth-telling
like i'm
obsessive about it um i
am obsessive about making sure kids have
fun but let's all do it
it's just become a part of us right but
it's these stories we're born into
these stories that we were told these
stories that we tell ourselves
and other people right and then the
actual things that actually happened
right
and so um some of these stories are
things we're born into
poverty right where you're born into
violence you're born into abuse you're
born into sexualization you're born into
race
culture gender sexuality some of these
things you're born and it's just
the narrative the air that the culture
around you is breathing
nothing you did or didn't do is just is
what you were launched
into earth with right in into life and
then there's these
um some and some of them are good right
that you are launched in
and things are going to work out for you
you got two parents who loved you and
you are connected
and you got one parent that loved you
and you've got people sacrificing on
your behalf
and and and people look in your eye and
telling you you're a person of value
you're gonna do really great things one
day and we're gonna
support you and care for you right so
it's whatever these stories that you're
born into
and then you've got these stories that
you were told
right the ones that that you were told
ah man like you would really be
attractive
if your teeth weren't so weird right or
you would be the best looking guy in the
world if you're
you didn't have so much acne if you just
fix your skin oh my gosh i should be so
hot
or or or right and then that's not to
mention the stories that instagram tells
you
about what attraction looks like and how
much sex you should be having and
um that it's viewer abuses
may have been your fault if you had just
not fill in the blank right
and then what happens over time is those
stories
morph into this is where i think it gets
really damning is
those stories that other people tell you
you start telling yourself in your own
voice
and since we always tell the truth to
ourselves right
then it gets hard right then suddenly
you're just that kid in the husky jeans
and you're 45 and you still don't like
what you see in the mirror
right and or you gotten a wreck when you
were a kid
and you still can't let go of the wheel
and you're so anxious and tense
and tense and anxious right and it's
story after story about them and about
you and about us and about tomorrow
about yesterday
and some of these stories i like to call
them bricks
this idea of bricks is is an analogy
i've been using for years with my
students
because they would come in with deep
anxiety or depression or frustration
and it was always good for them to step
out and say hey what are you carrying
around
into this class because they look around
this classroom and they think man i'm
the dumb one here i'm not as fast here
i'm not the fill in the blank
and i'd say man you're trying to compare
yourself in a sprint race
if you're just staying even you're
carrying around 100 pounds more than the
other guy over there
you're actually faster and stronger than
he is you're just keeping keeping pace
right and so over time i learned more
and more about
um this word that's become i guess in
vogue now and thank god it is because
we're having some great conversations
about this idea of trauma right so we
think of trauma about being it's
something like you're in a car wreck or
you go to war
spouse cheats on you apparently sudden
suddenly dies and that's true
right so you have trauma that the nerd
word is acute
i call it big t trauma it's the big ones
right you are a little kid and you're
playing tag and
somebody you you reach out to get
somebody
you know giggling and then all of a
sudden wham they hit a wall and break
both wrists and start screaming
um because they're experiencing pain
they've never experienced that's a big t
right that's big t um i've experienced
big t that i'm not gonna talk about on a
on a podcast right that's mine
right um and then there's a a huge
moment for me was with my good friend
lynn jennings dr lynn jennings she's a
trauma researcher um as well as a
child counselor in texas
and she helped open my eyes to another
side of trauma which is this what
i'm going to call little t trauma right
it is
cumulative trauma trauma that adds up on
you over time
and so if you think about bricks being
big t trauma right you walk home
and you find out that your husband of
seven years is cheating on you
and everything that you were anchored to
is suddenly severed
um or your uncle sexually abuses you and
he's the guy that came over and
um was your babysitter and your parents
trusted him and nobody listened to you
that's big t trauma that's a cinder
block that goes in your backpack for
for for years right but then cumulative
trauma
is um
when you come down the stairs every
single day and your mom says
oh honey that shirt that sure makes you
look pudgy and you want to be
you want the boys to like you don't you
want to be a pretty girl pretty girls
aren't pudgy
and you go yeah yeah yeah and you're six
right and so you go back upstairs to
change
that's a little rock that goes in your
backpack every time
every time mom didn't hit you she didn't
throw something at you
but she just said ah you aren't good
enough and you're gonna need to change
and cover a part of you
up so that others will like you others
will think you're valuable
and those i call those little rocks and
they go in your backpack and over time
it's cumulative
little t trauma adds up over time and
suddenly
those same little rocks add up to the
same weight as a cinder block
if you look at a at a public school
teacher has been teaching for 40 years
sometimes they'll
literally walk hunched over a little bit
right
and so one day your counselor pulls you
out of class and says hey your mom
passed away that's big key trauma
right your mom tells you every day um
you want to be loved don't you right um
that's a little t it adds up and it adds
up and it adds up and it adds up
and ultimately the weight in the
backpack is the same
right and so when you hear callers on
this show all the time
one of the things i'm always trying to
get to as quickly as possible is what is
that person carrying
what are they carrying that's making
their journey from a to b
harder to get to right so um
here's the deal at the end of the day
these i
i started re-examining my how what i
thought about trauma and it's informed
by peter levine
who we'll link to these books in the
show notes wrote an extraordinary book
called uh waking the tiger and um
i think that's the title of the books
that's how the book i think that is
it's waking the tiger and the body keeps
the score by
bessel vanderkult and here's what they
they really open my eyes and help expand
my definition of trauma even further
is trauma is not the event that awful
moment
and in fact there's been a lot of
studies on memory that will tell me or
suggest to me that my memories aren't
always so
reliable what is reliable
is that my body sounds all the alarms
it remembers and so trauma i've stopped
defining is what happened
and i've started re-examining my body
for
when does my body set off alarms in the
present
anchored to things in the past trauma is
any time your body responds to a past
situation
as though it's happening in the present
right so vanderkolt says that trauma is
much more than a story about the past
that explains
why people are frightened or angry out
of control trauma is re-experienced in
the presence
not as a story but as a body reaction
right
so you may experience this when you get
around some
you see some guy and your friend shows
up and like hey this is tom
and your body just goes get out of it
right who knows where that trauma
setting off you may know
right or when i see kids running and
playing
together in a cafeteria man my heart
starts racing
because my brain has been scanning the
environment for the last 30 years
waiting for that moment
and saying we remember what happens when
we do this
don't do that and so i have to then
go oh those are just kids playing the
chances of that happening again are
basically zero
they're gonna have a good time what i
need to do is address my body
or like a trauma situation we would show
up to a crisis situation where let's say
there
someone had been shot um and people's
bodies were still responding as though
there was an active shooter in that
building
what we would do is we would say hey we
need you to be present now
it was scary then you're okay now you're
safe now
right and so we the analogy is those
that traumas those bricks we carry
and you begin to go through your
backpack and look at these bricks and
examine them
for truth right and so over time of
course your knees hurt and your back
hurts and you have stress headaches you
have all these bodily responses to these
things that happened to you in the past
and it could be as benign as
man you lied and got busted when you
were 14 and you took on the identity of
i'm a liar
i'm just a a scummy idiot
or it could have been that you were
sexually traumatized as a kid or you
were beat up as a kid
or that coach told you you can do
anything
or that coach told you you're such a
wimp
you'll always be a wimp right and so
ultimately
one of the most important things i think
for folks to get to is to a
you got to know what bricks are in your
backpack you got to unders
you got to do that hard work to find out
what stories are in there what stories
were you born into
what stories have you told yourself what
stories were told to you
and you got to demand evidence from
those stories you got to look at them
and say is this true
did i lie when i was 14 yes i did did i
play tag with a girl and push her when
she was
9 or 10 and both of her wrists she broke
both of her wrists
i no i might say that i broke them i
shoved her and she hit a wall
that happened yes does that mean that
every time kids play
someone's gonna get hurt no does that
mean i'm a guy that hurts children
no right and so i'm looking at these
bricks and demanding evidence
and then the hard work is actually
setting them
down right so i would want everybody to
start and i'm in the middle of writing a
book on this
it's become somewhat of a
connection between folks that i didn't
never anticipated
that everyone is starting to recognize
how much crap they're carrying around
right and it could be oh i thought all
republicans thought this and i thought
all democrats
hated america and i thought all parents
who
right we just carry these stories these
stories these stories and i also say
this
media um often has a vested interest
and you carrying a lot in your backpack
a lot of
identities you were always going to be
nothing more than the worst thing you
ever did
you will always be nothing more than the
worst thing that's ever happened to you
because the more they can keep your
alarms spinning the more they can sell
you a solution
they can offer you a result and they can
offer you something to make it go away
whether it's
you just need some you time or a new
class or new program or a new
type of therapy whatever and what i want
to tell you is there's another way
and the other way is getting with
people that you care about or that you
trust often with a professional
counselor depending on
the level of trauma that you experience
the big t trauma and even a little
teacher i'm as a kid
or as an adult and taking those breaks
out of your backpack and just
setting them down those backpacks get
really really heavy
and so we're fortunate here after the
break we're going to talk to somebody
who was in the audience at that
presentation
at that talk who called reached out to
us and said hey man
what i do now and so when we get back
we're going to talk
to him and i'm looking forward to this
conversation i know you will too stay
tuned
[Music]
hey before you skip over this listen i
know that sometimes we try to sell you
stuff on here during these breaks but
today i'm gonna flip that around and
give you an opportunity to win
cash not really cash amazon gift cards
but same thing right
listen we're the most surveyed group of
people
ever in the history of the world and i'm
beat down by surveys just like you
right you go to a drive-through and you
just want to get a burger
and fries and some weird diseases all on
your own
and then by the time you drive through
they're texting you hey will you answer
five questions about no
no i just want my burger right i get
that surveys
are super lame so here i come at you
with a survey but here's the deal here's
the deal
this show has always been for you about
you and you
are critical to what we're doing here
right so we're doing our very first
listener survey for this show
please don't roll your eyes i know i
know i know but listen i want to hear
what you enjoy
what you don't enjoy i want to hear what
you want to hear more of in each episode
do you want more interviews more callers
any specialized topics teaching segments
plus we've got to get to the bottom of
whether we need more horse noises or not
right what guitar is the best
all that stuff i want to hear from you
right so text the word survey to 33789
to take the survey
and i'll enter you in a chance to win a
50 amazon gift card
that's survey s-u-r-v-e-y-33789
just text that and it closes on friday
july 9th so do it today
i want to hear from you all right we are
back
and i'm excited to talk to anthony from
saint paul minnesota anthony what's up
my brother how are you doing
i'm doing pretty good yeah uh it's great
to have you
at summit and uh and get to hear you
talking and he's gonna talk to you
one-on-one
afterwards as well so well i appreciate
that man i'm looking forward to
checking in with you man so you reached
out and
i guess the crux of your of your
question was
how do i get these bricks out of my
backpack i know they're there uh what do
i do next so
talk to me about what you were
experiencing during that talk and as
you've come home and
talked to your family and experienced
your work situation where are you what's
going on
well so after spending some time really
contemplating on the
on the bricks and everything uh there's
some that i can really identify
easily okay but there's some that i'm
sure are there that i don't know
anything about so
um i kind of interested in wanting to
journal to kind of work through some of
what i know and then also um if there's
any
advice or tips on how to kind of
discover and weed out those ones that
aren't i'm not aware of at this point so
how do i find out what's there that i'm
not seeing
so how do you find you man you want to
go spelunking right so you know there's
some big rocks there
you want to know hey what are the little
rocks that may be there what are some
ones that are buried on there i don't
even know that they're there that i may
be carrying around unnecessarily
um so what are one of the one or two of
the big ones that you found
um well some of the big ones are uh i
grew up in abusive house
um so i'll call it dad abuse both
regard to mom and their kids as well so
i know obviously that's one of the one
of the big
huge ones there yeah um and then some of
the
smaller ones but still bigger are some
in regards to appearance
and um growing up not having a whole lot
of
money and things like that so those are
some of the other ones and i'm sure
there's
a lot of other ones there that i'm not
seeing this
um so yeah just kind of how do i deal
with those bricks now that i
have identified them and how do i work
through
kind of uh just examining them and
making that plan to
move forward with them and then also
what else
how can i find what's down in the bottom
of that backpack
down in the corner and been sitting
there forever and
in the dark how do i identify that and
pull it out
yeah i love your heart there dude um do
you have
are you married you got kids yep yeah
i'm married and
five kids okay five kids wow fantastic
and tell me how the
the old bricks of an abusive childhood
or alcoholism
or poverty or body image issues how do
those things
pop up when you are um frustrated or
exhausted and interacting with your wife
or with your kids
um i i find myself reacting a lot the
way that i thought my dad reacts
okay kid a lot of explosive uh
bursts just anger and frustration
yelling things like that
so um what is that when you find
yourself yelling exploding
being angry what comes next
usually it's one of two things blame or
shame which one for you
um i i feel shame uh after the
situation's over obviously
really i know that i didn't hear what
right and
um the way that i do act
and what do you do next um
not much at this point really um what's
your what's your go-to numbing behaviors
how do you check
out because shame hurts bad and most of
us especially high-performing folks like
you
have a couple of go-to behaviors
um i think i think i just shut down i
just
turned inwards i don't
know sweet sweets are always a hard
thing for me so i think i
over indulge in that a lot but uh i
think
i think i just shut down in terms of
stuff there okay
well it's not okay to talk about you
know that's kind of the
soundtrack of my childhood as things of
having alcoholic that's not something we
talked about so
ah okay do you struggle with alcohol too
know do you struggle with any other
addiction besides sweets
nope no
um do you struggle
with um being right
and if you don't know the right thing
does that usually mean um
it's time to go to war i'm gonna defend
my position or
do you check out then too um
yeah i get very defensive so i have a
challenging question don't think so
okay what is defensive feel like for you
all right i feel i feel that i need to
be right
right so i really just put it up like no
i'm not wrong and just kind of deflect a
lot of it back and
even though i sometimes i know that i'm
wrong i'll still
put up the fight as if i'm i'm not
ah because we're gonna defend that honor
right
okay number one thanks for sharing that
man um
i promise promise promise there's
millions and millions of men out there
and women out there with very similar
experiences and responses
so a couple of things if you've got
stories in your past that include
physical abuse
sexual abuse alcoholic parents
um who either weaponized their fists
or i'll even venture to say
equally possibly even worse depending on
the level of physical abuse
a weaponized silence um
neglect who just was that hovering
presence like a bear in the living room
you knew you don't
go wake that bear up you don't talk to
that bear you just stay away
for a kid um
that sort of silence can be so
devastating because they think that
they're the problem
in a little kid's head why in the world
would my dad not want to talk to me
why in the world would my dad not love
me enough to go play ball with me
it must be something i did and so either
kids feel so ashamed by that
sentiment that they they go inside their
own cells they go into their own hole
or they spend their lives trying to be
seen
whether that's spray painting something
or making straight a's but they spend
their life
trying to make sure dad can see me or
mom can see me right
and so if you've got that story in the
in your backpack
on top of a story being you're born into
a story of poverty
right which is both checking account
issues and
psychology right it's an ethos
it's a way of being it's uh that's the
way we are and then on top of that
were you a big kid growing up what were
the body issues
uh no just uh mostly you know physical
appearance and
had horrible teeth my whole life well
that's kind of one of the big things
as well okay um see i i didn't hear you
speak directly into the phone there
yeah uh so the physical was more just uh
just just overall general looks um you
didn't think you were a good looking guy
yeah okay all right and so then you
almost not almost but you have to start
figuring out how you can disappear in a
crowded room right
um i need to be there but i don't want
people to see me and that stuff
haunts you forever so here's what i
would tell you number one those three
bricks are enough to keep most of us
busy for a lifetime
and trying to dig up
any other quote unquote things that you
may be carrying around
at for a while at least will be a
distraction to
working through those things and so
man you've got a lot in your backpack
and i would strongly recommend that you
go sit down and meet with somebody that
you can be one-on-one with
and be honest with a professional
therapist a professional counselor or
psychologist
that you can be one-on-one and open and
honest and say some things that you've
been carrying around for a
long long time have you ever gone to
counseling and met with people over
these issues
um i know as a child i've done some but
not in 30 years but okay
so i think the season is upon you
and there is story after story after
story of people who go
to counseling carrying the stuff that
you've been carrying
and literally they lose physical weight
their body starts to go because you've
got a kid inside of you brother that is
still scanning the environment 24 7 365
even when you're sleeping
for when the next shoe is going to drop
when the next person in relationship to
you is going to come in swinging
when the next person is going to come in
and take something from you the next
time you're going to have to move and
then have to move and then have to move
or somebody puts out a cigarette on you
or whatever the thing is there is a
nine-year-old that is still scanning the
environment trying to keep you safe
and that's why you respond like a child
when people threaten your honor
you come out swinging right and
there's a child protecting you defending
you going to war for you
and dude that wasn't supposed to happen
that's what nine-year-olds are
supposed to do they're supposed to play
a lot and have fun
and they're supposed to be tethered to
mom and dad and have a safe place to be
and i'm heartbroken for you that you
weren't i'm really
you're an extraordinary man that you
have been able to carry this around
and have five kids and be a good dad and
be a good business owner and be a good
husband
that's a testament to how strong you are
and now you're just going to use that
strength you've developed over the years
on another set of tasks and that's
cleaning this thing out
and so what i would tell you is when
people ask me how do i know
what i always want to do is i want to go
to those numbing behaviors and reverse
engineer that that's a great way to
um that's a great way that's simple for
folks so for me let's say it's sweets
almost 100 of the time when i have a
relationship issue i just go start
eating
it's really bizarre and i watch it
happen in real time and i know what it
is
and so um i know that when i'm feeling
lonely when i'm feeling like
my wife isn't appreciating me if when i
feel like she's
mad at me or i did something stupid or i
feel like i've failed my kids
with something i didn't fail them but i
did something i wish i wish i hadn't
said it that way i wish i'd said it this
way
i did i just head straight to the fridge
i head straight to the pantry and so now
i know
that when i start heading there i will
stop myself
and i'll ask myself this question what
is my brain trying to protect me from
and for some folks it's alcohol for some
folks it's pornography for some folks
it's texting an old girlfriend even
though they've been married for 10 years
for other people it's always getting the
last joke in other
everyone's got numbing behaviors that
they default to
um some folks it may be i'm always going
to be right i'm going to send that email
back now
i'm gonna take that that hit of feeling
good right now and
fire that email back even though it's
gonna cost so much crap for the next 48
hours
whatever it is for you find those
numbing behaviors
find those explosive behaviors and begin
to reverse engineer it because it's when
you catch yourself in that moment that
you know
oh no that's what that is right
and most of us most of the time who have
experienced what you've experienced
that's really really hard to do on your
own you're going to need other people in
your life
starting with a counselor then probably
with a group of guys that you can trust
and be with
um another great place to start do you
trust your wife anthony
yes i sure did so it'd be awesome to
let her know this is coming and say i
want to talk about making some major
changes in my heart stuff i've been
carrying around since i was a little kid
and i want you to speak into it because
i trust you you're the only people in
the world i trust
um i want you to speak into some things
that you see me do and
when you know i'm stressed when you know
i'm hurting you know i'm frustrated and
you know i'm angry
and i bet she could rattle those off for
you right away and there may be a couple
that you don't even know you do
i didn't even know i did some of them
until me and my wife had this
conversation
and then it becomes about getting the
help that you need and really dude i
would
let the other stuff go right now
you've got a lot a lot a lot of healing
to do how many people report to you and
your organization
do what i have i have eight people that
are under
eight if they had one word to describe
you what would it be
i don't know would it be
would it be generous compassionate
intense
angry frustrated what would the word be
caring yes that's awesome that's like
one of the greatest
i think it's one of the greatest things
a compliment someone can pay you so it
may be that you circle back
and you give those guys permission those
men and women permission hey i'm i'm
going to work on some
some changes i'm going to work on
putting some of these bricks that i've
been carrying down for years and years
i'm going to work on putting them down
heal from some old abuse that i suffered
as a kid some old challenges
and i want to start treating everybody
nicer i want to be more plugged in with
my family i'll be more plugged in with
you guys here at work
um you men and women here at work what
are some things you notice
because every boss has them right what
are the things you all know well we
better stay away
what are the things that take the air
out of a room when you cross what are
the similarities let them speak into
that if you trust them
and in doing so being vulnerable with
them they
have permission to be vulnerable with
you and you won't weaponize that
information you won't
um set them on fire that information but
you will use that information and you'll
take that to a counselor and you'll say
hey here's what i've been dealing with
the last 50 years
i've been dealing with childhood abuse
been dealing with alcoholic parents i've
been dealing with poverty i've been
dealing with
i got five kids and i want to be a
better dad i've been dealing with man my
knees hurt my back hurts i got headaches
all the time
i gotta eat start eating better i don't
think i'm a handsome guy and that still
haunts me to this day even though i've
got a
an awesome wife i've got five kids right
here's some things that people around me
say about me when i get stressed i go
immediately to
fights when i get stressed i go
immediately to the refrigerator when i
get stressed i go immediately
to the bar and have too many drinks and
i got an uber home whatever those things
are for you
take that slate take that that white
board of information
to your counselor and say i'm ready to
start healing i'm ready to get these
bricks out of the backpack
and then over time journaling will
become part of that for sure
community and being seen and heard will
be a big part of that but you're going
to start with looking at
therapists in the eye in person
preferably
and saying these things out loud there's
something about grief that has to be
witnessed
and it becomes healing when other people
witness it other people
carry it with you they don't judge you
and they still love you and often we
need a professional to do them
so that's a that's how you go about
looking at these bricks you go back and
look at these stories
when you've got an alcoholic man that's
a forest fire you gotta put the fire out
and then you're gonna go back and you're
gonna start digging into what did dad
tell me
what did he communicate to me he
communicated to me that alcohol is more
important than me he communicated to me
that when i did something it was so bad
that i didn't get to be in a
relationship with him
that was the part of the weapon um i
learned that being poor
being in poverty was so bad that i'm
gonna cat i'm gonna i'm gonna avoid my
my kids my wife i'm gonna do everything
i can to never ever have that
and there will never be an amount of
money that i can earn and never a
business acumen i can i can achieve
i'm gonna still need more and more and
more because i'm always gonna be running
from that thing
that story right were you poor growing
up yeah it's true
is there such thing as enough yeah there
is right
so you're gonna look at those bricks and
you're gonna demand evidence from them
was that nine-year-old kid worth hitting
no
was that nine-year-old kid worth being
silent to for two weeks
nope right and you're going to go
through those with somebody
else preferably not your wife at this
point and at some point they're going to
bring your wife into these conversations
as a part of the counseling process
and you all are going to re-learn how to
be in a relationship together
you're going to learn how to talk to
each other how to solve problems because
she's got walls
you know thicker than a than a school
bus
that she's set up to defend herself
against you over the last 50 years too
and so she's going to work through these
things also i want you to grab a book
anthony called i don't want to talk
about it by terence real we'll link to
it in the show notes
um it will be a transformative read for
you um you get the audiobook or the
the physical book but i want you to read
it i want you to go through it and i
want you
to i want you to let it soak in um
because he addresses this exact same
story
and i want to thank you for your
vulnerability and for your willingness
to call so
um good folks i know it's a little bit
different of a show but this idea of
trauma this idea of let's get to know
our bodies in the present
this stuff happened in the past and it
was evil and it was wrong
and some of it was little tea some of it
was small and we've been carrying it
forever some of it was big
and some of it we've told our story
ourselves these stories so long and they
weren't even true
so i'll leave you with this um i've been
seeing a counselor for the last year and
i called my dad about six months ago
i said hey this is gonna sound crazy i
seem to ask you this um
did i there was a big blow up when i was
a kid
involving a local church and me and
all kinds of things and i called my dad
and said
hey was that my fault did i do that when
i was 12.
and he got quiet and said no man why did
you why did you think that
and i exhaled in a way that i haven't
exhaled in so long i've been carrying
around
that particular cinder block it was four
or five cinder blocks duct taped
together for
25 or 30 years and it wasn't true
didn't happen right and there's other
bricks that i've discovered along the
way
thinking oh my i didn't know i was
carrying that that one's
heavy i had to go get somebody to help
me take it out
and look at it and examine it and set it
down and then what learn new ways of
coping and walking it's hard and it's
messy and it's worth it every single
time so i want you to know that you are
worth not carrying all these bricks
around you are worth
not carrying all these stories around
you are worth forgiving yourself you are
worth
being forgiven you're not the worst
thing that ever happened to you you're
not the stupidest
thing you've ever done you're not the
stupidest thing you ever said
you got to go clean some messes up yep
you got to forgive some people
yup you got to set bricks down
absolutely
absolutely but it starts with
getting out of pen and paper like
anthony did journaling writing these
things down what are these stories that
i'm
telling myself what are these things i'm
carrying and they will come out and they
will come out and they will come out
and if you got nothing for sure go see
somebody because
the other thing you got fight and you
got fight i mean you got fight you got
flight you got running away
and then man when you can't fight it you
can't run your body just goes into
neutral it shuts down
and a lot of us have been shut down for
years and years and years and years
and guys we only get one shot at this
crazy tiny little life here
live it well so let's don't be shut down
anymore let's stop fighting and stop
running and let's go put these bricks
down so thank you so much for um
sticking with us on this special
trauma edition of the dr john dolone
show and i'll leave you with this um
i asked the guys in the booth for a song
for today
this one's a little on the nose but i'm
gonna go with it
it feels icky now nope we're gonna go
with it today's song
the greatest song of all time another
brick in the wall part three
here we go i don't need no arms around
me
and i don't need no drugs to call me
i've seen the writing on the wall don't
think i need anything at all no i don't
think i need anything at all
all in all it was all just bricks in the
wall
all in all you're all just bricks in the
wall
what a that's not true
you do need arms around you
you do need arms rocks that's it you're
not just another brick in the wall
this has been the dr john delaney show
[Music]